selbst ganz willkommen zu einem neuen
video hört ja vor einigen tagen machte
dessen endlich bestraft wurde und die
strafe war für mich katjas 19
vorzubestellen
das habe ich getan und mir wurden heute
auch die restliche welt bestraft denn
der sommer ist jetzt offiziell draußen
natürlich werden auch wir neben gefühlt
80 prozent von ganz youtube deutschland
sind sollte mal anschauen ich werde
natürlich darüber ab lässt hat ich werde
menschen beleidigen ich werde versuchen
existenz hin zu zerstören
selbstverständlich aber dort sagt man
uns schon wäre natürlich zu sagen weil
ich deswegen spielen wir da eine runde
bingo katja coverversion also kann er ja
ein krasser bingo ich werde jetzt auf
diesem blatt papier sechs begriffen und
ihren sechs wörter von denen ich denke
dass sie in dem video auftauchen und
sobald drei dieser weiter gefallen sind
werde ich dieses video abrupt in dem
moment wo die drei wörter kommen ist
dies wieder zu ende
und meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren dann ist es auch schon soweit ich
darf in die liste für die heutige runde
krater bingo vorstellen wir haben ein
erster stelle natürlich für euch ganz
klar dass damit hat er mich auf jeden
fall nicht fehlen da haben wir nachts
für den fall dass ein anderes wort
verwendet mund weil der song ist nie
gelitten also dann haben wir viertens
hart weil das leben so hart war erstens
haben wir natürlich simon ist blöd davon
geht am meisten aus dass es mal
drankommt und an sechster stelle haben
wir kommen und wie gesagt wenn drei
dieser batterien kommen ist dieses video
auf abruf vorbei
[Musik]
und erst wollte ist gefallen und gebe
leute hab ich an der stelle ab was war
das deine lutscher ich kann es wirklich
nicht die die betrachtung dahinter
kennen die leute hat er gern mal lucio
der zuckerguss raus gespritzt der luchs
relativ rasch aber gebt euch das mal
bitte was die meisten von euch wenn das
nicht kennen aber madonna die sowie von
madonna politischen ballettstudios
abwehr und hat die genauso an zugang
und ja ich sage ich auch gar nicht
relevant gerade ich habe mich wisst ihr
was gerade deutsche passiert heute ohne
scheiß ich glaub ich habe keine panik
schaut leute ich glaube katja will
einfach so helene fischer mäßig so ein
ballermann star werden merkte dass diese
musik so gut dass man das irgendwie
stören kann auch mallorca jahren kann
ich glaube katja will einfach die 60
jahre jüngere etwas mehr um approbierte
deutsche helle der fischer werden [ __ ]
alter auch immer geil wäre jetzt ein
standbild der macht die dinge aber so
sieht irgendwie immer so aus als hätte
dass sie so gerade tolle ein in die
fresse bekommen weil stimmen gescheitert
[Musik]
ok dann unabsichtlich gestürzt aber ist
es ein fucking bitcoin lieder aus ihrem
primären geschlechtsmerkmale vorkommt
wer hätte gedacht dass man auch so an
bitcoins kommen kann aber auch gut an
der stelle die emotionale story von
ihrem aufwachsen in der roth damals
waren die taschen leer jetzt kostet der
körper mehr als drei jahresgehälter von
normalen menschen in deutschland das ist
natürlich eine steile karriere
kleinere okay ich hab gerade mal eine
minute weiter geht's gibst du die
letzten minute hat sie nur dicke lippen
gesagt ich hole texter zwischen ich
glaube es ist wirklich super kerl ich
gesagt andererseits sollte stellt euch
vor ihr seid im familien- oder und ihr
seid familienvater mit drei kindern auf
der hütte und die freiheit da ein
bisschen wenn katja kommen mit dicken
will ihr als sie ihren vater dann singe
ich habe dicke lippen und sie blasen
werden eure kinder leben dann am tisch
sitzen
das einzige was katja aufstieg zur pop
version von den fischern noch aufhalten
kann
warst du schon listen geschaut und ich
habe nur ein wort ist herr angestrichen
sie entweder ich habe mich darauf
konzentriert zu verstehen dass dieser
text bedeutet man hat vergessen ihr
weiter abzupacken oder katja tatsächlich
einen song ohne die wörter feucht nass
fahrt kommen und sie man uns blöd ist
kein wort ich verstehe es gemacht
schauen wir doch mal ganz kurz in die
kommentare leute und nicki minaj
zeitpunkt 0 oder nein
helene fischer 2.0 selena körper hat
schreibt ich höre meine klasse am montag
schon sinkt ok ich muss gar nicht weiter
was sagen wollte bücher und erst hat die
sache schon zusammengefasst mit seinem
kommentar größter möglich das war's dann
tatsächlich andreas vielen dank für
diese zusammenfassung bleibt stabil
bruder
und jetzt diskutieren wir weiter